he went on dates with like a hundred  guys do you feel like what what  percentage of them would you like be  interested in a second date oh gosh well  I mean what are the prerequisites for  the date just like  um like like randomly or are they like  because because she like that's a good  point because she'll Peck him out and be  like do you think like he's cute yeah  there's got to be some degree of  selection because if you're bringing me  something like 50 year old lady I'm just  gonna be like no yeah I mean I don't I  don't know if I'm even gonna do that  episode we'll see  um I don't know if you find love on the  internet what could be better than that  for the world to see yeah I don't know  we'll see